what's that a hat crazy funky junkie hat
hair inside me trying to look like cute
at nightly no that's not some
wizard-like magic
we've saved the wizard world like ten
times i think we got this it's actually
selena gomez and jennifer stone
reuniting to recreate their iconic
wizards of waverly place song
what's that a hat crazy funky junkie hat
you're sucked hair inside me trying to
look like you nightly we've been there
we've done that we see right through
your funky hat
a cowboy hat
it all went down on tick tock the former
co-stars were seemingly enjoying a cozy
girls night with some adult beverages
when they decided to indulge fans of
their long-running disney channel series
and take a stroll down memory lane
what's that a hat crazy funky junkie hat
ever sucked hair inside me trying to
look like keira knightley we've been
there we've done that we see right
through your funky hat
they totally nailed the choreo but it
took them a few tries just check out the
bloopers selena posted on her tick tock
story
beanie
what's that a hat
what's that a hat crazy funky junkie hat
you're sucked hair inside me trying to
look like cute or nightly we've been
there we've done that we see right
through your funky hat and get this
selena's on-screen mom maria
canals-barrera slid into the comments to
give her stamp of approval love this
love you too we hope everybody enjoys it
and we just gotta say we're obsessed
with how much selena loves looking back
on her wizards days
oh my goodness yeah it's amazing
she shared a mashup of clips of her
character alex russo just being the most
relatable
so you're telling me that i have to come
up with a solution all by myself to a
problem that i created all by myself
i'll handle it like i handle all of
life's problems ignore it until it goes
away i'm not lazy
i'm just resting up for my 30s well guys
time has flown and our girl sg is now
approaching her 30th birthday in july
[Music]
and like her character on wizards selena
is fully embracing the new decade well
sort of last time i was single i was 24
and the dating pool was everyone and now
it's like a shallow puddle of
age-appropriate men who are old and
gross and i don't want to do that that
cell recreating a scene from leslie
mann's character in the other woman the
caption me walking into my 30s i'm okay
with it though i am so excited and while
cell's laughing over her dating life her
career is on fire
not only did she recently land her first
grammy nomination for her spanish
language album revelation i cried like a
little baby i was very excited
and i worked really hard on that project
so it was
a lovely surprise i'm very excited she's
also garnered critical acclaim for her
performance on hulu's only murders in
the building she even scored a critic's
choice award nod i think we should just
hit him with the chart good
excellent so i'll take the lead on this
excuse me well i can turn on the charm
is it on now
it's just warming up elena what was it
like for you to get the call to work
with these legends i could barely keep a
straight face just hanging out with them
it was so wonderful and i learned so
much being around them they're legends
in their own right but they've you know
they're good people humble funny kind
and professional and it was just the
best
but respectfully after seeing selena's
latest tick tock the project we're now
most interested in a possible wizards of
waverly place reunion till then we'll
have crazy hat running on a loop
what's that a hat crazy funky junkie hat
you're sucked hair inside trying to look
like kyra nightly we've been there we've
done that we see right through your
funky hat
[Music]